selon vous à qui correspond ce
pourcentage regardez le chiffre dans le
barco
et oui
alors je me passe de c'est la taille du
sexe de machin c'est pas du tout mon jeu
je veux du nouveau Benoît 2023 j'ai
changé le rapport avec l'argent alors 5
% non pas du tout le taux du Peel c'est
assez rapport avec les femmes avec les
femmes
tu as vraiment non
Natacha
on a une voyante qui va venir il faut
vraiment que tu lui parles
est-ce que c'est drôle ou plutôt
sinistre non c'est plutôt en fait c'est
plutôt triste on se rend compte que ce
soit pour les femmes ou pour les
homosexuels il faut
avanceront jamais l'amour on rigide 5 %
des femmes c'est le pourcentage des
femmes qui sont apparus dans le top 20
des personnalités préférées des
Françaises tu as raison on avait jamais
vu ça
expliquez-moi en quoi c'est grave parce
que il y a eu 503%, il y a eu l'égalité
parfaite au départ dans les nombres
composés c'est la faute de qui si et les
hommes et les femmes ont voté pour des
mecs c'est peut-être triste mais c'est
comme ça
[Rires]
voté pour des mecs ça a l'air d'être un
combat première femme et 20e et il y a
eu et il y a 17 je sais plus combien je
vais vous dire le chiffre il y a donc
voilà Jean-Jacques Goldman premier
toujours c'est Foresti qui est la
première à la 20e place mais sinon il y
a quasiment bah aucune femme je peux
commettre le son
c'est savoir que quand même il donne 120
Mathieu 120 noms et après il demande aux
gens sur ces femmes pardon
c'est un sondage fermé ce qui fait qu'en
gros il présente 50 hommes 50 femmes à
un panel de merde et doivent dire quelle
est leur personnalité préférée parmi ces
100 personnes sur
120% de femmes 50% d'hommes et qu'ils
ont voté donc ça c'est comme ça ils ont
le charisme tout comme ça pardon
et les gars on met des mecs
et hommes il y a quand même des trucs
qui sont complètement hallucinants
il y a pas Nagui il y a d'autres
animateurs il y a panique il y a
Philippe etchevestre il y a pas de Nico
s'il y a pas Nagui mais Nico s'il était
dans les 100 proposés je peux vous
demander quelque chose est-ce que je
vous pose la question est-ce que pour
vous le plus gros scandale pardon 2023
c'est la nuit dans la gueule de le plus
gros scandale c'est que c'est Goldman
1er alors évidemment bah personne n'a vu
depuis 20 ans et le mec qui reste numéro
1 on l'aime pourquoi juste parce qu'on a
bien sa musique
j'adore Jean-Jacques Goldman mais il dit
à Londres il prend 2 millions d'euros
par mois qui touche de la SACEM il est
chez lui il fout rien alors il lui
donnera une asso c'est tout mais il est
subi il faut rien il est premier l'abbé
Pierre était premier j'ai même plus mais
il consacré sa vie aux autres mais
Goldman qu'est-ce qu'il a fait cette
année une chose pour nous dans ma
Pesquet
Michel Sardou pour nous Jean-Jacques
Goldman
Matthieu un truc on va parler de
Brigitte Bardot tout à l'heure elle a
fait pour la première fois son entrée
dans le top 50 donc on sait la
personnalité qu'elle représente la
France c'est l'une des plus grandes
stars
là-dedans parce qu'ils l'ont proposé
dans le panel des 100 personnes mais si
ça se trouve l'année dernière
vous savez ce que c'était que la
conclusion pour moi comme un politique
dès que tu disparais les sondages monte
en fait quand on ne te voit plus les
antennes non mais c'est vrai un Goldman
on le voit pas il aime tous ceux qui
sont plus là
Mbappé parce que ils ont vraiment fait
le but exceptionnel cette année mais les
hommes politiques construit un très bien
que quand ils disparaissent un an tout
d'un coup hop dans les sondages il
remonte parce qu'on les voit plus en
fait quand on te voit plus on t'aime
c'est un truc qu'on devrait peut-être
appliqué en couple aussi c'est qu'il
passe trop mal
ni Vianney
ce qu'il est ce qu'il est propose c'est
des potes qui sont entre eux à mon avis
tu appelles un coup de tête à peine et
tu dis je peux y être cette année je
connais machin qui connaît machin tu es
dedans enfin voilà
personne détestée c'est ce sont les
mêmes c'est en fait c'est une question
souvent de visibilité
il y a eu son fils
un jour un jour faut que j'aille un jour
faut que je dis il avait été animateur
détesté des Français et il m'avait dit
c'est pas grave du tout tu es premier ou
dernier j'aime au milieu